Okay, so to close one deal a week, how many ads and sites would you say and business owners
I need on the hook per week to close one?
Depends on its close rate.
Right now, you're going to need a lot more.
Right now, I need like a bazillion more and it's still one.
Well, right now, you don't know because you haven't closed one, but what I would say is
if you haven't closed one, just go ahead and go off with like a 25% close rate, right?
So you've gotten two because even if you close your next one, you're at a 33%, right?
Yeah.
If you close the one up that year, 25.
So 25 would be a very conservative number because guys, it's not like you're just getting
on this random people.
You guys are getting on with warm people that are already paying for ads, they already know,
they already like it.
They tasted the nectar, they tried the Costco sample.
These guys are ready to be closed.
So 25% is like very conservative.
So if you want to base it off of that, but also remember your close percentage right
now is going to be vastly different from your close percentage by midsummer when you're
getting damn good at this.